I said a couple of months ago and I've
said it multiple times that if you're
wishing for or waiting around for the
impeachment or resignation of Donald
Trump you should really think about
whether that's the best thing because if
Donald Trump were to be impeached that
might enable Republicans to actually
start getting things done if they get
out from under the constant media
pressure around Trump Russia and the
inability to actually get stuff done
Trump's impeachment could end up hurting
Democrats in the midterms or in the
primaries and I floated the idea I think
it was about six eight weeks ago that
the best scenario for Democrats could be
for Donald Trump to stay in office
riddled with the constantly growing
revelations about Trump Russia unable to
do a damn thing as a result of
constantly doing damage control for it
and this could serve as a sort of
reminder to voters in the 2018 midterms
or in the 2020 election of the atrocious
disaster that people voted for that has
gotten nothing done for two or four
years at that point that has sort of
been coming to fruition we are now
seeing a level of paralysis and
increasingly finger-pointing at the
White House which have really escalated
over the last seven to ten days as a
result of the Donald Trump jr. email
scandal with the Russian lawyer a top
Republican close to the west wing said
that the quote White House is paralyzed
Trump again is off on a trip this time
to Paris with zero additional
accomplishment since the last trip the
health care bill is on life support at
least the most recent version of the
AHCA from the Senate the tax plan who's
even talking about the tax plan barely a
mention of the tax plan for weeks or
months administration officials are
saying that Trump is barely leaving the
Oval Office over the last few days his
emotions are ranging from furious to
frustrated and that outside the Oval
Office it's just a blame game of
finger-pointing from one aid and staffer
to another Trump publicly is trying to
deny that this is what's going on he
tweeted before his trip yesterday quote
the White House is functioning perfectly
focused on health care tax cuts reform
and many other things I have little time
for watching TV although if Trump says
that you can almost certainly count on
the opposite being true people on
Trump's legal team are saying that Trump
is furious Trump is watching TV that
he's been angry with his personal lawyer
mark Kazu it's apparently Trump is not
liking mark caso it's his strategy which
if the strategy is to try to get heat
off of Trump Russia March Casa which has
admittedly completely failed with that
the legal team on the other hand is not
happy about how Trump is handling the
Russia issue the legal team is
reportedly displeased that Jared Kushner
is going around them and talking
directly to Donald Trump about what's
going on with Russia without keeping
them in the loop in the loop it's leaked
that it's not off the table for Trump's
lawyer mark cow so it's potentially to
resign rumors are flying that members of
Trump's family want chief of staff
Reince Priebus to resign and the reality
at this point if these truly are the
conversations that they're having Pat is
that your problems are way bigger than
Reince Priebus right I mean this is like
trying to fix a car that's got a
backfiring engine and the exhaust system
is missing and it has no wheels by
changing the wiper blades oh just fire
Shawn spice or two and it'll be okay you
know we've heard a lot about how maybe
the Trump Russia scandal will be bad for
Democrats because all the media is
focusing on it and allows Republicans
especially in Congress to sneak through
the backdoor and do whatever they want
there and to some degree they have and
yeah just some to some degree that's
true
but if it means that the White House has
to focus on how they're going to respond
to the scandal hire all these lawyers it
means that they're diverting their
attention to that stuff and not their
disastrous agenda 100% and and let me
add one more a piece of data that we've
learned about from the New York Times is
great reporting recently this could be a
major revelation and it's basically
going unnoticed and I read in detail all
the New York Times reporting on this
yesterday Paul Manafort okay Paul
Manafort who is one of the most at-risk
individuals for possible criminal
wrongdoing in the entire Trump Russia
fiasco Paul Manafort recently mentioned
the meeting this infamous trum
Jr Kushner Manafort meeting with the
Russian lawyer men afford himself
according to the New York Times
mentioned the meeting to congressional
investigators that are looking into
possible collusion if Paul Manafort the
person along with Jared Kushner most
exposed to criminal charges is
apparently cooperating with
investigations and and proactively
disclosing meetings that took place
that's not a good sign if you're Paul
Manafort in terms of the direction that
this may be going arrives me of Michael
Flynn requesting immunity to cooperate
fully with the FBI very very similar so
what are we hoping for at this point
number one
I hope mark Kazu 'its does resign Donald
Trump had a big problem finding
attorneys even willing to represent him
he found mark caso it's if mark has oh
it does resign that is not going to be
good for Trump number two let's hope
Paul Manafort is feeling such pressure
from this investigation these
investigations that he continues giving
bombshells to investigators and number
three let's hope for continued paralysis
for the White House because just about
everything Donald Trump wants to do
federally all the big federal
legislation Trump is working on health
care tax reform building the wall with
Mexico I mean it's almost hilarious to
even think about the possibility of a
Mexican wall that Mexico will pay for at
this point it's just a joke at this
point everything that Trump wants to do
is basically bad if they're paralyzed by
dealing with this that's a good thing
for the American people I think that if
the year ends and Republicans are able
to do virtually nothing when it comes to
health care when it comes to tax reform
yeah what reason will they have to stick
behind Trump especially if his approval
ratings start to dip even more
interestingly his approval rating has
not dipped more it actually has trickled
up just slightly I mean we're still in
the same range of 36 to 40 within 3%
margin of error but I am genuinely
curious we don't have approval numbers
that are that are new right I mean we've
got approval numbers from a couple of
days ago that will collect it over the
prior three days the Don Jr story broke
that's exactly right
I don't know what impact that will have
but we will probably know by tomorrow or
Monday send me your thoughts what do you
think about this paralysis and
finger-pointing at the White House I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show follow either or both of us today's
program is made possible in part by
movement watches I'm wearing my movement
watch today movement watches was started
in an interesting way by two Broke
college kids who didn't want to spend
four or five or six hundred dollars on
watches that they liked and what they
did was move there or or create their
business with an entirely online sales
platform so they removed the middleman
as well as the retail markup and they
have watches priced as for as little as
ninety five dollars on their websites
really a fraction of what department
store brands charge
they've got classic design and and
styled minimalism and they've now sold
over 500,000 watches in more than 160
countries two of those watches are mine
of that five hundred thousand plus
watches I've got one with this lighter
face another one with a darker face I
get compliments on it everywhere I go
and I am encouraging you to save fifteen
percent on a movement watch and get free
shipping and free returns at MVM
t-dot-com slash Pakman ok that's 15% off
your watch free shipping free returns
MVM t.com /pa km am